y el que ingresa al pentágono como el
primer afroamericano en liderar lo lloyd
austin fue confirmado por el senado como
secretario de defensa en una decisión
bipartidista casi unánime a su cargo
estará un controvertido presupuesto de
750.000 millones de dólares militar
durante 41 años el general retirado
prometió respetar el control civil de
las fuerzas armadas
bersuit la seguridad de nuestra
democracia exige un control civil
competente de nuestras fuerzas armadas
la subordinación del poder militar al
civil pase toda mi vida comprometido con
ese principio
en su carrera austin rompió barreras
raciales como ser el primer
afroamericano en liderar el comando
central unidad responsable de las
operaciones en medio oriente durante la
presidencia de barack obama fue una cara
visible de las operaciones en irak y de
la lucha contra el estado islámico pero
su nombramiento también ha despertado
dudas por un lado no cumplía la norma de
llevar siete o más años retirado de la
fuerza por lo que debió recibir un
permiso del congreso por otra parte
antes de su llegada al gabinete de
bailén
a la junta de directores de reid en una
de las principales contratistas del
pentágono e implicada en la venta de
insumos militares a naciones como arabia
saudita que los utilizó en la guerra en
yemen es importante que el secretario de
defensa lleve a ese papel una
independencia de pensamiento y es muy
preocupante cuando un nominado proviene
directamente de uno de los principales
contratistas militares para calmar las
dudas
austin aceptó duplicar de dos a cuatro
años el periodo de recusación sobre la
toma de decisiones que involucren al rey
de ons y se comprometió a no volver a
trabajar en una empresa de defensa o
como cabildero cuando deje su cargo